on ouvre ce journal avec ses frappes
ukrainien hier soir qui ont touché un
village dans la région de brillance que
dans l'ouest de la Russie deux personnes
ont été tuées dans le village de suzanka
un immeuble a été complètement détruit
d'après le gouverneur de brillance les
jours précédents l'Ukraine était
elle-même bombardé en pleine nuit à Uman
dans le centre du pays 23 personnes ont
perdu la vie vendredi les opérations de
sauvetage sont aujourd'hui terminées on
écoute les précisions de notre envoyé
spécial sur place Gulliver crag
des applaudissements pour la fin de
l'opération de sauvetage
autre continuer les recherches dans les
décombres plus de 150 membres des
services des urgences ont été mobilisés
de la région de Tcherkassy ici et aussi
de la région de Kiev
le bilan final est de 23 morts dans 5
enfants c'est les sauveteurs vont s'en
aller la douleur le deuil et la colère
reste
que c'est mort
et ne soient jamais oubliés et quant à
ses fasciste de russe qu'il crève tous
j'ai entièrement rejeté la longue russe
c'est la langue de l'agresseur des
barbares
nous ne savons pas si nous allons
pouvoir retourner chez nous on attend
l'expertise
je n'ai pas de mots je ne sais pas
comment les gens qui prennent ces
décisions dorment la nuit
les Russes ont dit qu'ils ont ciblé une
base des réserves Ukrainiens avec cette
frappe un peu plus tôt nous avons
demandé à Odessa à la porte-parole de
l'armée ukrainienne dans le sud du pays
sa réaction moi
nous ne pouvons que montrer ouvertement
à quoi ressemble le site de l'impact si
c'était une base militaire pourquoi il y
aurait des enfants selon vous
effectivement les autorités n'ont placé
absolument aucune restriction sur
l'accès des médias à ce quartier il y a
eu une deuxième frappe sur le bâtiment
derrière moi c'est un entrepôt
appartenant à une entreprise de
décoration un peu plus loin il y a une
caserne militaire mais les habitants de
ce quartier disent que depuis des années
cet immeuble était inoccupé que ce soit
vrai ou non que cette caserne a été une
cible ou non les Russes l'ont raté de
presque 1 km en frappant les meubles
d'appartement